The earliest known academic rating about the meaning of random was by John Venn
in 1888 and his book called the logic of chance. He said, Perhaps the best
typical example that we can give of the scientific meaning of random
distribution is afforded by the arrangement of the drops of rain in a shower. No
one can give a guess whereabouts at any instant a drop will fall, but we know
that if we put out a sheet of paper it will gradually become uniformly spotted
over. And if we were to mark out any two equal areas on the paper, these would
gradually tend to be struck equally often. Therefore, when we have a random
sample, each subject has an equal chance of being selected. And then our sample
is more likely to approximate the population.